[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I can't wait forever I'm not that
patient I've got too many things to do
you're comfy like a sweater but when the
Sun comes out I won't be needing you
you smile conceals a secret and it's a
sickly sweet that I can't see the point
of taking deeper and through a selfish
life it's just so beautiful
I don't
please don't leave this to go cold
your rides making me feel dizzy when you
quiz me on my childhood
I'll share with you if you so kindly cut
me hole so I can
[Music]
I threw the rag soaked for the clothes
you straight on to me but instead I
enjoy this view that I so shallow
[Music]
I don't
while mice
[Music]
Oh
things are graduating for what you did
sir cream would you only see them now
right here's where we both are and too
afraid to turn
have fun
I
[Music]
I won't be easy
[Music]
your genes are in shock you just like
put your thumb in the box yeah
[Applause]
hello hey guys
pushy a little bit hi thank you for
watching
Jesus it's happening this is Jamie and
the song that you just heard was
produced by Jamie all the music that
wasn't a ukelele was Jamie and you
didn't sing on this one but he did know
I'm one of the songs fun yeah yeah he
did the harmonics yeah yo y'all hear it
if you want to check out the EP but we
have been reading your comments guys
thank you so much I'm so freakin glad
you liked the music video I will be
publishing that on YouTube after this
stream but you guys got to see it first
before anyone so how lucky are you also
that was Jamie's first time seeing the
music video yeah complete thoughts yes
good yes good he did say the
green-screen was better cuz when he
first summer at the green screen was a
bit messy oh my god yeah my hair and
green-screen
[Music]
but I did my best
so yeah congratulations dude thank you
so this is the live gig it's you know me
just nice and chill in my bedroom never
leave the house it's gonna work and then
come back home again so I thought why
not just invite Jamie over and then we
play the songs for you because we have
been practicing if you didn't know by
now the EP sweater is out on Spotify
Google Play
iTunes Apple music that's the same thing
right she is about to get retired music
diesel but no one uses diese Amazon yes
good cool title no maybe as a lot say
it's like over 100 stores or something
yeah it's it gets put on pretty much
everywhere so if you want to listen to
sweater brave face fresh start and
there's a little extra there that I
won't spoil for you yeah someone
commented and he tweeted me actually
saying like what is this progressive
rock wasn't thinking that's 9 minutes
long but yeah that's a little surprise
then you can listen to it now so yeah
we're gonna we're gonna play for you
it's my landlady happy she heard no she
hasn't she's not here at the moment so
we got the whole house to ourselves we
can be as loud as you want which is
great I've got it on Google Play this
morning Thank You Elvis what how did you
how did you find it what did you like it
like you're worried that where's your
thoughts will play for you a bit don't
worry we'll play all the songs and a
couple of extras Thank You Gabriel for
following on Spotify I think yeah so
I've got a link in the description and
that'll send you to everywhere I think
that it's been put up on to getting on
the prog rock yes I mean I could
probably write rock music yeah
and then all I have to work on is my pig
squeal thanks for buying it Tom oh he
got he got the CD oh yeah so Elvis got
set my the CD but he doesn't ever see
but do we have I've got we do have some
left which I will look into getting them
but they will like this so I I did all
the paint for it oh my god what is this
I don't know oh no Cass wants you to
explain the ghost in the video okay sure
I can talk about the ghost um I feel bad
I missed that one
what was that I just need to move it out
the way of
one sec I'll put the zombie on your side
okay um so yeah the oh yeah wait I was
gonna show them before I answer your
question I'm just messing with the
little booklets as well and I'm so
freaking happy with these because I
spent I spent forever photoshopping Amy
and I did a photo shoot for this and I
had to photoshop out so many freaking
like shadows and creases to make this
look decent and like I think yeah I'm
really proud of myself and all of this
and then all of the patreon you're in
the special thanks and so are you Jamie
can we do it later oh really I think
easily the same as the one you sent me
for no it's updated changed it I've
changed some other pictures as well um
but yeah see I put your little logo
well thank you so yeah that was what the
patreon Scott if you are a top patreon
and you're waiting for yours don't worry
it's on the way I already sent it I know
a couple of you have become patreon is
very recently so I'll send yours ASAP
but yes others are on the way anyway
Luke has explained the ghost the ghost
actually is not Amy
hey Amy the ghost is Amy's boyfriend
Jackson so if you stop the obviously I'm
gonna upload the the music video but if
you stop at the end with the credits
it says starring Jackson done as a ghost
cuz that's that's who he is he's the
ghost but obviously that's not about him
weird he's the one who yeah that's nice
of you it's just about like your past
and people in the past that kind of
haunt you and get in the way of of
something and the song is basically a
like kind of about when you're not sure
like you feel like you kind of might
need someone or want someone but then
you realize that actually you can be
your own source of light and you don't
need someone for that so that's kind of
what he represents oh my god there's a
spider on my laps
uh-huh always goes down behind hey oh my
god why he's got little white spots on
his butt alright wait we should probably
get this spider out do you guys want to
watch the music video again oh well I
get the spider out I kind of say it's
probably on the back oh no on the end
can you see it yeah that's on the end
there wait if I open the window okay
watch the music video again and then
we'll be right back and then we'll be
singing for you I'm sorry I need to get
rid of this spider okay
be right back watch the music video
again have fun be right back for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I can't wait forever I'm not that
patient I've got too many things to -
you're comfy like a sweater but when the
Sun comes out I won't be needing you
you smile conceals a secret and it's a
sickly sweet that I can't see the point
of taking deeper and through a SAP
inside it's just so beautiful
[Music]
I don't
while your son
please don't make this to go cold your
eyes making me feel dizzy when you quiz
me on my childhood his movie I'll share
with you if you so kindly cut me hole so
I can
[Music]
through the crack so food
you straight on me but instead I enjoy
this view that I saw shallowly
[Music]
I don't
while mice
[Music]
Oh
rather waiting for what you disagree
what you only see them them right here's
where we both are and too afraid to turn
have fun
[Music]
[Music]
I won't be easy
[Music]
your genes are in shock you just like
put your thumb in the bottom there yeah
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
new okay the ghost fell zero times just
so you know and we had a kerfuffle we
tried to open the window and then we
ended up slamming it shut and then we
tried to open it again and then the
spider disappeared so cool action might
come back at some points mm-hmm but hi
Katie thanks for coming and also we were
reading your lovely comments and thank
you to everyone who's giving comments
about the mix about the music video
really appreciate it are you gonna do I
was gonna say you can do a blooper reel
someone awesome oh yeah yeah so um I
wasn't even the behind-the-scenes video
to the film is cuz they said they wanted
to do it but I haven't heard from them
in like months so I think I'm just gonna
do it myself
spiders vanished I don't know where it
went
yeah I mean I'm just gonna put the
spider outside but then they just kind
of yeah I don't know but yeah don't
worry there'll be a behind the scenes
cuz it was funny so that that shot I
don't know if you remember that shot of
like the ghost like running towards the
camera that was like she just random
like behind the scenes but it made it in
can you cover this on hell again but
first let us sing it to you it's like a
livestream often they wish yeah I don't
worry I wouldn't kill the spiders yeah
we if it's dead it wasn't intentional
yeah I didn't wear a crew down the back
of the laptop I think yeah oh maybe went
in the inside the computer yeah we just
like I go to type and I see this
like legs just like a freakin that's a
great premise for a horse anyway I've
had what I've been working had spiders
crawl out from under the monitor like
across the desk before on that free
glass okay let's get comfy guys were
there any sweaters I didn't think
sweaters had feelings you might pull the
thread or something I mean this one's
still alive
this is doing I was wrong okay should we
sing well okay
[Music]
I can't pay for rabu another patient
I've got to anything city account fee
like a sweater where the Sun comes out I
won't be needing you smile can't see the
secret and this is a please
sweet that I can't see the point of
taking deeper and through it's a place
that is just so beautiful I don't wanna
spoil your soon
please only if there's Togo come your
eyes make me feel dizzy when you quiz me
on my childhood history I'll share with
you if you so kind they caught me also I
can see I can pry through the cracks so
cold like clothes from you straight on
to me but instead I enjoy this view that
size solution only and me I don't wanna
spoil my soon
[Music]
please don't leave this to go cold
if the best things are worth waiting for
desecrate what you only sing when right
here's where we bow and to upbraid turn
around
[Music]
I can't wait forever another patient too
many things to do I can't feel like a
sweater the Sun comes out I won't be
needing for listen guys I forgot we need
to check here for for twitch just in
case oh that's a nice Thank You Gabriel
the music video for that is even better
so what we just did to do to hear live I
guess they just like a different vibe
right I guess yeah thank you very much
Christine Christine good ear and Lenny
and Tom and Elvis and montage and who
the hell is that Barry and Nicky and
Raymond DJ and my girl wait didn't you
guys play your instruments with so much
grace and position it's just inspiring
not only you guys time to playing your
instruments but Yasmin's voice is so
soothing to know that there was one
vehicle there was a very precision that
I did on that song but having it live is
a whole new experience
that's my way doing this I'm glad you're
enjoying it I
um actually I guess we could sing
another one but then during you guys
maybe unless you already have some do
you have any questions for us about the
EP about working together about some
questions now and then do another song
yeah but if they can't think of anything
we can't stand why they think of
questions no too busy doing everything
and getting that so that the fun fact
that video literally exported 10 minutes
before the dream and I was just like on
the floor like oh my god because they
wouldn't it couldn't get it up in a
window and then I had to like a little
moon I like had to send it to the cloud
on OBS so yeah like don't think that I'm
this person has it all together
I don't and Amy knows that for sure why
anyone help with you with making your EP
I guess you can ask answer that right
why is anyone help you like why would
anyone help you to help you with this
I mean why why did you help me uh
because I liked your songs pretty much I
thought you had a great I could probably
do something with music as well I mean I
mean you bloody well did how can we
support Yacktman acts and horizon
productions
that's a good question Tom listen to
Spotify again and again and again so
we've got 50/50 on only revenues from it
so if you just listen to it again and
again and again or if you buy it to be
fair it's also they buy on Google Play
and iTunes
that's only one sure is just one
revolution I think the best one is a
Spotify stream and we do we do have
plans maybe in the future of doing like
another album yeah yeah and then we were
chatting about um a horror podcast II
thing so I guess it's like if you guys
really like like what we do
like we could look into ways of getting
right now I probably can't do it I don't
know how much no different process I
actually looked into podcasts and I
can't use this for a kid for it or
anything because they just do music yeah
so probably just going to SoundCloud but
obviously that's like you know but it
would be fun because it would be like
stories got it on repeat thanks Amy what
other people have said what I mean what
have other oh I'm glad you like the
diversity on my channel eternal Lenny
cuz I'm constantly like beating myself
up about that but some people like it
Thanks I'm uploading for the minority
it's a good that's true that's true the
community is [ __ ] great
yeah awkward Jamie you wanna really get
thought you'd be more cuz you're not
used to this if they were all singing
from up
does the song make you think of anyone
from your past um yes but I'm not going
to say Hugh cuz it was written around a
time a certain time but it wasn't a it
was it's not bad pressing this not
present I think it was very short-lived
but I think that's kind of like the
songs premise right is this a
short-lived thing because I realized
that I didn't tell morning on Spotify
now cheers Elvis
the only question that I have is another
song when in that live sorry what do you
mean a weakness together the lights on
now another song in that I yeah I think
yeah when are you gonna play another
line okay let's do it let's sing our
songs you guys keep asking your
questions if we don't respond just at me
or something yeah I'll see you but think
of you questions we'll sing the next
song next song is the next song on the
EP and that is very face brave face okay
[Music]
pile under my stress but the past I
can't see you here with me and though
expand so many yeah I'm still trapped
beneath my fears and if you like to see
mine is great
who'll be behind my
[Music]
come from that calfskin fighting watts
where then a smile fool
Granta t like you hear me and though
it's been so many yeah I'm still trapped
beneath my fears and if you've changed
my and stay behind
[Music]
pray to say wits you led astray I'm
expected to pursue a bond when I was
held by Titus and though it's been so
many
[Music]
I'm still trapped beneath my fears and
if you have an imprint of me leave me hi
[Music]
they gay that was the next live song so
if you guys sort of in question yawns
does Jamie sing his own songs Jamie is
extremely talented musically though he
plays a lot of different instruments the
way you sing the way you sing a bit
Bollywood and thank you guys because I
grew up I go for love hearts and for
four hands and four clap spoons for
heart eyes by always thank you for
coming and it was great seeing you in
Jamie form I'm glad yeah I mean you guys
can start asking your questions again
now any other guy would try and go from
and don't worry I think I saw someone be
like we only have one question you can
have no oh yeah GG gap she played
perfection also Jamie is the guy who did
the music behind perfection so now you
get to see yeah so he was the one that
made it made you all spoopy when you're
walking down the hallways and hearing
all that noises also use the the mail so
that if you chose a female you would
have like female breathing and crying in
which oh yes yes yeah and the voiceover
series
you want to do something what did we say
when prepared for perfection
Oh cuz that was Jamie yeah that was me
going like I wanted you to like say it
how you did yeah see that's Jamie
Wow so good I was in the moment then I
remember yeah it was sort of like sort
of 1960 Star News BBC yeah that's kind
of why I was channeling so to speak okay
so got a new one too far yeah we got
here did I get through there I don't
know I don't know Johnny to me he means
the Heian thing yeah I don't know what
ion is which bit what's the lyrics
around yeah let us know what what
sentence it was singing and I'll let you
know you kind of a killer man I'll say
me honey from yesterday
okay so questions questions questions
[Music]
what did you enjoy the most while making
this EP that's a difficult question
because there were so many breaks
in-between because I was doing
University it's like three years before
Christmas
maybe turn off years yeah yes this did
take a while because it was doing my
yeah cuz I was Jim Jim University so
obviously that's when I was making
perfection alongside so yeah there was a
lot of starts and stops but today like
the best part about it I don't know
really just I don't know I mean when I
was editing the behind the scenes at the
first day in the studio I was like you
know I knit too much because I knew that
you wouldn't and also you shy away from
the camera anyway so was I trying to
hide a lot yeah like you're talking you
have your back good camera phone yeah so
maybe maybe the first day I don't know
just like hearing it all come together
and stuff like if I was going I don't
know how much you perv the original
version of brave facing because it's
really different to what we ended up ya
know they didn't really do much but ya
know i guess what others so jamie is a
music converted for games composer for
games as well I'd like to be I am trying
to work on more conversation work that
yes he can do games so if anyone once
game get into a crack give it crash
[Music]
would you use a CA our parent is years I
don't know today it's pretty good ask
the audience it is either that most
popular tools uh I don't know it's free
I know they use like a bunch different
stuff because we use
yes you probably use custom stuff yeah I
think customers know we do we definitely
do actually because I know that the
audio dudes put means in it that
question what's the meaning behind the
music video and the art of the EP if you
don't mind me asking of course not
so the meaning behind the music video
why I've already spoken about that I
think enough I mean if you want me to go
into anything specific specific but for
the art of the EP so I wanted it to be
kind of like my version of wearing my
heart on my sleeve but nature is my
heart because I love nature it's where I
feel like I belong that's where I feel
the happiest yeah and I love being on my
own in nature so I wanted to show that
through the EP just like this this
lonely but beautiful place through me so
yeah like and that's why I kind of made
it thank you for following oh cool an
attic oh you like yeah yeah so I yeah so
the whole premise of it was kind of like
that I was like covered with what I love
and that's the only thing that I was
wearing so it's like green screen or
whatever and that's why my feet of muddy
as well so it's like it's always a part
of me so even though I'm in the real
world in the white boring bland world
I'm always like yeah got my got my mud
it was here else do you have favorite
songs off the EP I know which were mine
is for what's yours
if you have one it's difficult because I
like different bits mm I love that final
chorus on press stop
yes it's so good yeah I wish I'm you
know the higher church choir that final
chorus on fresh start if you guys
haven't listened to yeses
yeah and then the synth sound I came up
with on yeah yeah brain face was
definitely the one that took him only
because we changed it like three times
yeah because we just couldn't get the
feel for it and like I knew kind of what
I wanted it she's pretty hard and we
were experimenting a lot oh yeah to
experiment so Oh tell them the story
about the ukulele and how you like
turned it into a weird sound oh the
black thing yeah yeah I just got to play
sort of four notes and I just turned it
back with something I think it delay
effect on and it made this really
interesting sort of weird reverse creepy
sound you might actually be in box
what do you driving maybe if you want to
play it I don't know if my computer
cannot know I'm bringing up Dropbox and
done I think it right now
not even in just a webpage oh we can try
come on I just well you saw earlier like
everything was just when you were
dictating a video as well yeah three
thank you for following by the way he
was a Oh basement cat
when is the next concert we actually
haven't sang live yeah we need to
properly put softly yeah this is the
first game to more people we played for
two people yesterday yes James and and
Katie hey Korra's Casey of course Louis
thank you for farah win I always feel
like I need two ladies and it's my
fantasy piece there yeah I'm finished
sort of finished since breakfast okay so
this is the original brave face it's
very bad the ending kind of if you play
from me I need to turn that light
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
great
[Music]
straight back to you
[Music]
[Music]
and then I get dropped and then I die on
the floor okay yeah that was that was
the first initial brave face so if you
have watched the behind the scenes video
well actually what the original thing I
was doing like a no no no I remember
this Oh
but yeah it's Arvika percussion there
you said it sound a bit too poppy I
ended up changing it to actual drums
which I think do sound better then
that's not super dark though yeah okay
next song don't do first our next song
guys this song to answer your question
who was it that asked us that question
of which is our favorite songs oh this
is my favorite I know I love this one
mainly for the third the third verse
it's so good and I mean to be fair it's
probably just cuz this is the newest
song so I still resonate with it the
most
[Music]
okay wait for it Tom
why oh he's afk he said he wouldn't have
que da oh yes semi afk so you might be
listening not talking that's fine
okay Tom you've got ten seconds everyone
give us a countdown no that counts I was
freaking hilarious I was like give me a
countdown and Tom gives a hundred and it
gets to one and then people start like
bringing back up again just like do you
not want the live stream just he's
probably listening I think he means semi
half cares in he's doing something I
think he's doing it's where I catch Dean
you keep working hard Tom some soothing
study you don't let us distract you okay
[Music]
this is just the story of a girl who's
sort of hurt she needed to forget being
a fresh start
be careful what you say cause she no
longer feels the same look at her eyes
see the students without me oh sorry for
I watched two peak in the time she lost
Wednesday's fountain like seconds since
both your paths crossed soda for a
sweater keeping out this cold weather
buddy he keeps her warm buddy
[Music]
she likes to think she's clever
so afar and they call secure thwen
you're so fickle and it over her heart
felted heavy and brutal sorry for a key
to faking a dignity Stonewall in a box
and by gars truthy this is just a story
of a girl who sewed her heart
now she's forgotten she's got a fresh
start
be careful what you say cause she no
longer feels the same look in her eyes
see the stains without shaming my love
can't you see that you can't even
breathe it's here's my B try but your
body will bleed I love why did you
choose your solitude could I fly your
ties but you left one loose my love as
you fade I have this to say
[Music]
where
first this was the way this is just a
story of a girl who sewed her heart
now she's forgotten she's got something
oh my gosh this is technical headphone
switch to blue - so I can make coffee
and listen I don't really know much of
that everyone wants to make some covers
I'm bi Reed fine with that call from it
and share to share it to to us so we can
see us address taggers inbox me DMS
I don't know why but I feel like I'm n
the end of something if I just listened
to this song without looking and the end
you're like like in the end of a movie
or something someone said that soon
before that that sounds like a credits
yeah - like some like rom-com wasn't
damaged rom-com yeah but like you know
yeah like a funny one Hong Kong oh yeah
yes coming the time would you meet the
test of the songs available yeah I
probably see that um this the tabs
actually are if you go on YouTube on my
YouTube page and so in the description
yeah but I probably need to put it on to
like good to top what is it called
Guitar Tabs Oh hold to my guitar dog yes
so uh oh I'll look into getting it on
that but for right now there are live
versions that I've just done on my own
when I first made them on my youtube
channel and in the description it has
the lyrics and it has the chords so yep
cool hard to pick but this is probably
my favorite of the yeah because the
endings if you haven't heard that like
on the album it songs and these eep-eep
it sounds amazing sounds good
thank you Amy thanks to fauna thanks
Gabrielle time for a tea break
enjoy your tea no I'm just like confused
it's okay you're just a super cool indie
girl indie indie girl I'm just an indie
girl
thank you so I guess I'll just I'll just
excuse if there were any other questions
and if not then I guess and Katie yes
you guys are taking our gig virginity's
[Music]
I think you answered most of them yeah I
think I did yes
oh yeah do I produce my music I do kind
of but I have trouble finishing it
because I don't have a deadline
deadlines made me worry if someone says
I need three minutes of music in two
days I can do that if I'm left to work
on my own music they just kind of do it
as I go yeah yeah no so nitpicking over
every little thing whereas when when I'm
doing something someone else so
obviously I try and keep the quality
high but you know you have to get it
done so you have to okay it's done now
yeah that's why I try to listen back to
stuff that I've done for other people
because I always like John and Hank
green I think they gave the best advice
one of them he said he liked the secret
to his success is that he only ever
strives for eighty percent never 100 it
was good advice oh yeah totally did you
two know each other before the EP no no
no Jamie just reached out to me I
remember it was it was around Christmas
right it was cuz I remember being I was
visiting actually you don't know so I
was visiting my mum and we were going
through like some stuff and it was like
a really [ __ ] time for me and then I got
this email from you and I was like like
it was really nice because I wasn't like
in a very good place and then I was like
ah and then yeah thank you
glad I helps him yeah thank you
r.i.p Montez scrolls up what she asked a
question like 10 times maybe maybe he's
asked that question and uh oh yeah oh
yeah he said hi I passed it higher up
dude come on we can't I got constant
sound playing that's the rule oh yeah oh
yeah no I can't I can't not a question
but we really appreciate you putting so
much effort into your EP that includes
the songs instruments lyrics and all
that as well as the video editing since
I've been pacing thank you thank you
and after the EP of course thank you
yeah yes we it's weird like when you
just focus on like little things you
don't realize how much you got she don't
I'm just like yeah I don't think I was
thinking of Photoshop yeah yeah that's
weird so when you're working you're kind
of when you're in the process that's
your mindset you're kind of doing little
bits when you get to the end of it I've
actually done quite a lot yeah
surprisingly yeah I think you everyone
needs after a project to like have time
to just sit back and be I just dunno did
this we did this we did this so oh that
the question got asked asked again about
you producing your own music yes oh wait
do you want to join a plug your music
wears on soundcloud probably set up a
band camp as well for the
but for some other music that might or
might not be on an EP yeah you can say
I'd say what I don't think it will be on
it to be fair
cuz I I don't I can't bother with the
whole cover stuff there were too many is
that on your EP the other thing oh wait
are we talking about the 9 minute one
yeah the the epic progress okay yeah
yeah oh that's not really my own why I
did right under a brief it might be the
start of a podcast now I'm hoping it
won't we yes experimentation I kind of I
do produce my music you just like some
really don't end up getting it online
because again it's finishing it from
mm-hmm you do some really cool story
pieces though which which is why I
wanted to do that like thing with you
because I think you're very good at like
understanding a narrative in a mood and
then getting that across functional
music yeah stuff a media mmm I prefer to
write that way anyway when I write
orchestrated pieces I kind of have to
have a little at least a narrative in my
head while I'm writing or us it's really
hard to just stick notes together that's
why I find it easier to work on other
people's stuff because there's a
definite this is what I want yeah yeah
doing my own stuff
I just like stick it together what's
this
what are your musical influences on
these songs or engine Eleanor hmm
so these songs a brave face Marika
Hoffman was a massive oh yeah you've
already sent me this um oh wait did I
send you low roar as well for that
I think oh yeah yeah yeah there was
another one he has a low roar so it's
very like um artsy kind of psychedelic
yeah yeah um I've really liked them
because I thought it went with the feel
because I wanted that song to feel very
more like as if I don't know like you're
inside my head or something and then I
don't know for sweaters to be honest
that one I just threw something together
and you happen to like yeah yeah I just
was listening Oh probably the guitar was
definitely on shiver
yeah lover be a Lucy rose um yeah yeah
there was probably that yeah and then
fresh start I said oh man I think it's
the same Lucy rose she was a big
influence of this yeah yeah yeah
Lucifer is and then for brave face
Marika Hackman definitely I won't see
that that quiet thing was an idea I got
from one of dirty songs little bit
second losing soulmate secondly I have
to say oh there you go then yeah and
then in general I'm I don't know
I mean Lucy rose and Marika Hackman I
always kind of may go to gals love them
there's also some people on YouTube that
I really like
but I can't remember the name no there's
like this one like vegan girl but she's
[ __ ] hilarious she's so funny and she
can sing like a dream
oh but also at the moment someone I
really admire is Eva stone and I covered
her
oh yeah of course yeah she watched that
oh yes
[Music]
but high voices do a fangirl freak out
yeah she was like with the harmonies
because she's got this voice is so
powerful so I can't do that so I was
like okay I'm just harmonized cuz I can
do that
both of you awesome aspect MERIS pick
you got some mapper speak from the
montage now because will you collaborate
and get in the future yeah like we're
talking about the podcast yeah it's not
necessarily music but maybe well yeah
well yeah oh yeah yeah there'll be more
music definitely I can't see a thing as
you want to well if I want to stop this
Chris yeah you were like oh yeah
actually by the way yeah so like we said
Dodie Cyclades and soul mates that was
kind of the inspiration for the end yeah
that was once yeah yeah also on Lucy
Rose the first time there's a lot that
starts well
we'll get around the microphone and are
you trying to find this person
yeah vegan ukulele strap Ouija one not
made of leather like a cop I need to
find her I need to find out she's so
funny I mean you guys really like her
that's not no no
she cut her bangs right I'm gonna I'm
gonna search that cutting my own bangs
she does that a lot dude some people
have done that what it's a pretty common
and messed up that was what the
suggestion how I cut my own it's easy
for a guy who just bought a Clippers
sorry guys I will be with you I'm just
on a mission to find find this girl so
cutting my own bangs begun this is like
having a vegan musician who cuts her own
bangs does anyone know there must be a
reason yeah there tomalak curtains make
sense oh wow we call it fringe in the UK
yeah at least in England though I never
heard the term bangs in tonight was
watching my American TV show
I know is way too many okay wispy bangs
she does a lot of these as well why
you're gonna get here she is
Haley babe Haley place oh she she plays
she does music
yeah she's such a good singer I I'd love
to hang out with her but I mean idolize
you know him real life she might she
might be completely different but that's
that's it so she's also quite
inspirational tortured what what is that
torture teenage style anyway that might
just be the name she came up for the
wind she's yeah yeah I mean she's
changed it to our no no no no no more
questions so I guess we will carry on
singing I don't know who II didn't
Eklund is kick the PJ hmm someone's
saying you should work with kick the PJ
oh that was super fun but no guys people
like him do not even look at me for like
me he's this stupid like but he's like
really creative and he makes a lot of
like stories he's beefing I would love
just to have the time to like make my
own stuff like that because he does his
job
hmm it'd be nice yeah it'd be nice okay
as I see feeds different
this one will also give me any comments
coming from twitch have a look at that
well yeah don't read it yeah okay
twitch is worse yeah I just want which
on YouTube
hey Lukey but I put on twitch Justin
just in case anyone's there bad news
okay so we've done all the songs though
on the EP but we have been practicing a
couple more for you so I don't know some
of you might not even know this one but
this one is called a robot you have a
nice you know you have on the roof hey
Tonka see someone on twitch so I can't
see oh is it okay yes this one's called
robot you might have read it you might
not but this is whenever we have time
I'm guessing this is probably gonna be
the next song oh yeah what I think you
may be making this one like a super
weird in row oh yeah yeah it was Katie's
favorite she's like robots robot yes
robot it looks like a lot of people like
it as I as I and if he's like you any
case'
yeah
[Music]
okay
no just another yeah the next DP just
wait another two years
[Music]
why is exchange father blood in my face
upload my thoughts flow them through
your maze recycle my skin so I can't
begin to love the shine
[Music]
my organs might be softer form but they
will not burst or Tyler rations pile we
push you and my skin might not
artificial but it makes me superficial
mask I'm all dictated by oh make me
[Music]
and emotions only leave astray the logic
that save-the-date ego all Zig actions
of our lives and freedom comes with a
choice and we've chosen to destroy the
world is our right to sacrifice but it's
not right so make me
[Music]
I've shed my skin for something more
rocket boots and laser beams in Lord
I'll fight for a cause because I simply
cannot stay and wait for a day where I
can't we just
[Music]
silence silence okay got you on Twitch
as well its its lucky again
this is so good you gotta cool you guys
it wasn't thank you shucks shucks revert
and goodbye Joker if the live stream is
lagging Raymond maybe try refreshing
maybe try refreshing the stream thank
you for all the clefts and the love
hearts this should have been the Wally
soundtrack yeah yeah maybe the next song
the next big Pixar burbot film yeah
Ravens like have to make a cover of this
every Sun I have to make a cover of this
yeah
cover UV I'm just gonna be you by the
way if anyone's having YouTube issues
apparently the twitch stream runs more
smoothly says basement the basement cat
so feel free to go over to twitch.tv
slash the YAG man X and it might be
better over there for you so yeah well
we only have one more song to sing oh
and she is it's helped us for so it's
getting near the end of the stream
anyway ah but before we sing our last
song should we show the sweater music
video once more yeah see what you guys
want if you want them if you want us to
play actually I can just play on a loop
actually after oh yeah yeah at the end
yeah see you guys can like watch it
again a few times twitch has a bad
compression algorithm so should work
okay
[Music]
going well that is good party I'm the
stream are goin't which has less delay
to like we can ask you a question you
can go like straight back adesso what's
your favorite song on the EP go
has anyone listened to the fourth track
as well has anyone listened to the earth
for nine minutes it's time for us to ask
you questions now I love this relay
[Music]
they will they will spawn this is the
delay yeah tell us your favorite song on
the EP great face oh that's interesting
that's a very very unique choice that is
you haven't listened to it yet why are
you here then go listen no that's okay
you can listen to it later it's on
Spotify it's on all things
Switzer robot robot smell on the EP Ani
fake fun fake fun very brave face little
fresh start sweater and yes
oh so Michaels listen to the story fresh
start oh my god
I wanna I'm gonna figure out like what
everyone's favorite is I will be torched
for not saying sweater but I will say
brave face nonetheless let the torching
be so I'm going to count this I'm gonna
count this so there is yourself a
strawpoll pretty face a straw poll straw
with withdrawals no as it is a website
where yourself a poll oh oh okay yeah
let's do this
wait Oh put then not oh yeah yeah cuz
then it would just be a link right and I
can guess so
was it close it like straws and straw
yes
create oh this should be a free type you
a question your favorite
you just got a nice close-up of please
taste my mash your favorite song on the
sweater ep someone who say track for ya
and what will have that whether it's
whether there's brain Beijing
yeah the washing machine is going mad
brave face sometimes I can feel the
floor shake because of it yeah it's a
very old house fresh start the Sun and
[Music]
yeah on by the way for those of you who
do get the CD or have got the CD there's
an extra song just for you it's like the
first song that I ever recorded in my
own bedroom and I could not play ukulele
like that or back then that sounded
quite you think thank you oh yeah no
definitely definitely that yeah
definitely now someone said shadow of
Peter Pan it's not on the EP though
could it be did you actually write
though the lyrics that was that you're
in creation shadow Peter Pan yeah I
wrote the lyrics for that yeah yeah
someone said it's their favorite Oh
who said that oh yeah oh yeah that was a
sweet sweet song
oh you haven't I haven't posted it yet
share this link Cheers
okay right boats for always restream
votes for your favorite song on the EP
okay guys you can use that straw poll
link to vote for your favorite song and
then I will check up on that at the end
and we shall see we shall see indeed oh
there's two there's only three things
yeah there's not great why do we get a
fancy pie chart fancy by John oh I'll
share with you guys there's a troll in
the chair oh I was looking for John
chord darude - sandstorm like I thought
those natural troll
oh ho PS you're such a letdown I wanted
to show this pie chart but it's not it
does this all the time it just doesn't
work whatever you can you can just check
out the pie chart for yourself I'm gonna
delete this okay okay okay you're back
just in time to vote on our on our vote
for what your favorites song was on the
EP hey go you can use that oh don't
don't apologize Raymond it's really
sweet that you want to make covers like
I'm very very flattered amazing right
now that's how she's saying sure Annie
[Music]
welcome my face chops
okay thank you my lord
slandering sandstone streams guys I did
it for Annie
Oh
[Music]
Gabriel's just asked for an acoustic
version to be put on Spotify we can
definitely do that that wouldn't take us
that long
yeah like once obviously we practice
more we can just make an acoustic
version yeah like we did with hey me
flat flower for a meet plan yes we do
yeah exactly yeah we do
I'm not gonna say we'll do it because we
have a lot of ideas it's kind of like we
need to prioritize hi girl hi Hainan
[Laughter]
well I need to refresh any weeks it's
not it's not like it's not streamed or
anything but we will sing another song
for you do that song yeah so you guys
saw this probably yeah there's already
brushed on the channel this is called
layers song and it's a song that I broke
when Princess Leia died bloody hell was
her name again
Carrie Fisher oh my god okay I told
Annie I'm like the whole stream is gonna
be me being berated roasting you over
here yeah okay
oh yes on accountant yeah you lit up my
childhood with your feelers my your by
then I'm pretty face you are going to be
wild dr. Cerf waits to you won't have a
bee
[Music]
thank you for sharing your hug with me
never know your impact spread through
more than one
bull's eye sight completely wrong yeah
mr. Bursch yeah okay
please the Sun and the demon cuz I sent
I can't play their life yeah that would
be pretty cool though life storytelling
knots ain't nothing we could do that now
oh yeah it was interesting that's going
Christian Henson who's composer do you
know the show was inside number nine
they did this anyway they did a live
version of the show say he had to
literally compose live so he had all his
samples set up and always effects and
they literally put out as a live I think
it was a Halloween extreme oh I wasn't a
stream that's on TV yeah yeah yeah for
that show
so like super high pressure situations
yeah I mean they do that I like it when
they do that III and stuff like okay
let's let's try right I'll try and get
it right
[Music]
you live my childhood with your Feliz
you're more than a pretty face you are
going to be wild
doctors the way to you will never be
defied
[Music]
your bravery its teeth reflected in
those share with you your story and then
watched it on
[Music]
general your dedication inspires
portable tea but hot rice but meet us at
my
[Music]
[Music]
okay yeah I tried to carry on for the
nose like not for Neil's like way too
much it's alright they can watch that on
YouTube yeah okay I think this is not
the end of the stream now I've been too
much for two hours so we're gonna check
the poll results fresh start fresh dog
seems to be with full votes
yeah I'm so disappointed only nine
people voted that's alright though out
of you nine people who voted there's
four people who prefer a fresh start
three people who prefer a brave face and
only two people assess whether that's
actually I'm actually really surprised
yes what it was like the Magnum oh yeah
I thought sweater would Venus up yeah
yeah yeah has gone very quickly
anyway thank you very much for watching
please do check out the sweaty ep the
link is in the description but also I
might as well just get out for you now
many links okay I'll get it up now and
also I will share with you
Jamie's SoundCloud yeah so you can check
out some of the stuff thing that he does
as well Twitter up even though this is
the best so yeah
I'll put it in restream
uh check out Jamie's other music so
that's Jamie's SoundCloud I do sometimes
put my own compositions up yes when I
actually finished see you guys can have
a little check out of all the other
stuff I mean you've also got the
perfection soundtrack on there too yeah
that's one spot and the soundtracks oh
yeah yeah so um I don't know if any of
you watch the the the Valentine's poem
but the music was done by Jamie damn so
so that music is up oh thank you Tom I
choose this fight over thank you
[Music]
[Music]
I think I'm just checking the poll just
once more just to see oh yes oh there's
a tie now guys shy is brave face and
fresh fresh start
because no one's sat through yeah oh
well no Michael Michaels listen to the
story I'm sure Tom swear we listen to
the story as well
I mean you Tom seems a little smiley
face
[Music]
and fight you effect oh yeah so Annie is
the one who's always in my Instagram
stories where I'm like choose this
fighter that's Annie that's Annie H
there
that's her okay the opposition is
fighting back
yeah that's let's share your your
Twitter while we're here because I why
not yeah I don't use Twitter much I'm
terrible at social media to be honest
that's okay that I do all the social
media for us anyway to show you it's
okay eventually every time this media
dudette yep Gabriel look go breath
isomers like they're on sides I'm a
fresh pushed our team um beefy steam
team face song team face still owns a
team face I'm the team fresh together we
are first base oh yeah
oh it was 1515 I don't know most of them
have just come let's gonna sell me stuff
let's get Jamie up to a thousand
finalizes who can do well yet none of
those people except I see there's a few
people I think you did to subscribe who
actually might be interested but a lot
of them are companies one of them was
the UK drum show this companies are
basically to advertise themselves they
follow you
oh yeah oh they make more kestrel
libraries especially on Instagram as
well yeah but it works through to a fan
yeah it does work but they wouldn't do
it
that's the funny thing he was a
marketing doesn't work then why do
companies spend millions on marketing
every year because it does work
obviously increase in sales it depends
it depends on the target audience and
the week about it
no of course all those things okay
the links those geezers Apple music
iTunes and Spotify yeah it's all the
main ones so you can you can check oh
wait come on
check out the sweats EP please love you
thanks okay and bye get me to a thousand
followers and I might actually release
something videos a lot of people you
don't need to be if it's not something
that interests you though is pretty hard
you know well it's more making of
building relationships and potential
people to work with yes because if you
make friends with people than they might
hand you jobs sort of thing like if they
can't do something like oh this guy
might be yeah yeah definitely going to
events obviously gives you that personal
touch but it's not as necessary these
days no it does take up a lot of time
there oh yeah absolutely
it's ridiculous I was like just how much
different stuff there is to try and keep
up with hmm
so it's got she'd quite nice
like I've only done social media page
once but it was very nice because I had
like no no buzzing no no if you sort of
set aside as part of your working day
like an hour to deal with that stuff and
just the rest of the day just ignore it
you can't you can't you can't do that
because if you want to be constant on
social media you need to be constant
like because as soon as you leave it cuz
I try to do that I tried to give myself
an hour in the morning
for work and stuff to do my social media
but thing is that people will ask you
like questions I'll talk to you about
something relevant and then if you
replace them the next day it's like not
relevant anymore or like you've left it
for too long and then it's all piling up
and actually in that hour you can't
reply to everything and so it's much
better just to kind of make it an
organic kind of thing so like whenever
you put something out on social media
you stay on there
I don't follow my own advice but you
should stay on there for a little bit
longer just to see who replies and then
reply to them like straightaway and then
at least you know you're a little bit
active and then people kind of
understand if they realize like oh okay
she made this post like five hours ago
if I respond now she might know what
applied to me but if they don't
straightaway they expect you to and then
it's all like Fran's in the image right
yeah yeah I suppose I'm just trying not
to piss people how do people who have
say millions of followers deal with that
they don't they don't list they're on
but that's the thing though if you have
millions of followers people like not
everyone but are more lenient because
they understand they're like look at
your number count like you must be gay
it's something for exit yeah like but
then like when you're when you're
smaller people think that no one
contacts you why haven't you point me
yeah it's like wait wait reply to it I
don't you reply to my friends that's
really bad hence why I'm me and Aimee
are thinking about starting a podcast
cuz we find it really doing good to stay
in contact yeah because we find it
really hard to stay in touch yeah we
nice anyway ramble about social media
over people just
not post my Instagram is literally one
patient oh no three pictures one post
which is just the students I should send
you some pictures that I've been taking
of your studio that's okay that they
need updating anyway because this this
stuff I've got the equipment is
different outlet why if you if you need
me to take some pictures I can do that
I've actually found a way I can put it
on a stand I found some clamps that
might work so we made during the
Princess Leia video we had I needed
better lighting basically and then Jamie
said I have a thousand watt light bulb
but against super hot and we didn't have
any stand or anything so I just put on a
piece of MDF so I didn't sort of melt
through something and it that almost
caught fire yeah we just started to play
and then like yeah the video was
recording everything and then just
watching those a little yeah it was a
shame because that was a really good
look great yes because you know you look
at it directly you'd lose your house
okay no yeah one kilowatt yeah proper
hold school didn't have a heatsink on it
I think the idea is meant to be it's got
like a thing you can screw to something
so there's obviously a stand but I
didn't it wouldn't it wouldn't stand on
no no but I did find some sort of old
drum clamps the woodwork and I'm
assuming the cases designed not to melt
from I think you also need to buy sheets
you know the covers for it well no
because they're designed they're
designed to you can look online I mean
with the way I'd used it before was I
just put a white sheet up on the wall
and then shop put the light facing the
white sheet in a reflective oh yeah I
mean just just directing it to the wall
works pretty yeah
okay let's start to say goodbye to the
people in the chat do you want to like
do you want to like play a random tune
and then I'll just like feed out names
and we're like sing goodbye I what do
you want me to play
Rhonda but just a little chord
progression
[Music]
[Music]
that's really some
[Music]
we've come to the end of the livestream
it's been a really nice tie
I can sorry yeah good luck gang hold of
one of those light bulbs now I think
they're illegal because of the amount of
wattage they take oh yeah an LED one my
dad's gonna LED evolve this super-bright
outside for like lighting sorry get
distracted
thank you for coming thank you for
listening thank you for giving us all
your support I can't thank you enough it
warms my cockles to sing to you and now
we'll say goodbye to a sweet lullaby but
don't worry
y'all play the music video again
[Music]
please listen to the sweater EEP it's
what has got me so happy and I can't
believe it's finally out [ __ ] me it's
finally out goodbye mantis
goodbye Joker goodbye my come Castilla
[Music]
goodbye Lucas if I call me death goodbye
your roswell and goodbye tom goodbye
Stefan Oh goodbye there's nobody else
talking in the chat but over on the
twitch side we have the basement
[Music]
basement
[Music]
by a sire you are enough don't you ever
forget it you're all enough for us
you're more than I ever expected
actually
[Music]
goodbye back to me and so happy to see
you stuck around to been around for a
long time and get by édouard wall I
think you were lacking I didn't see you
here before
where else was goodbye Raymond TJ thanks
for coming and thanks for thanking me
too
[Music]
[Music]
and thanks for everyone who's not in the
chat it's been a lot of fun and it's
more than that this was my dream since I
was a kid I'd sing my mom's ear off and
now I'm on Spotify also Thank You Jamie
[Music]
[Music]
and goodbye Ronald
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I can't wait forever I'm not that
patient I've got too many things to -
you're comfy like a sweater but when the
Sun comes out I won't be needing you
you smile conceals a secret and it's a
sickly sweet that I can't see the point
of digging deeper and through a SAP
inside so beautiful I don't
please don't - Coco's rights made for me
to feel dizzy when you quiz me my
childhood
I'll share with you if we can
[Music]
through the racks of food
you straight on to me but instead I
enjoy this view that tae-soo shallow
[Music]
while my
please
Oh
breath waiting for what you disagree
would you only see them now right here's
where we both are and too afraid to turn
have fun
[Music]
[Music]
I won't be
[Music]
your genes are in shock you just like
put your thumb in the box
yeah
[Applause]